the assassin's creed series tells an
alternative history of the creation and
development of human civilization
and it all ties back to an ancient super
advanced species
that ruled over earth long before the
assassins and templars even
existed spanning over a dozen games the
lore of this massively beloved series is
vast
but the semi-magical throughline of all
assassin's creed games and the age-old
battle over ancient technology is
secretive
and altogether more complex there will
be spoilers ahead but let's dive in
and see where this series and the origin
of humanity
all began
long before humanity's existence there
were those who came before
the first civilization that ruled earth
over 77
000 years ago were called the isu the
isu were a super advanced ancient race
of humanoids
that were better than humans in just
about every way
with longer life spans sixth senses
instead of five
and even triple helix dna structure even
though they seem a bit like aliens
they were native to earth and were a
result of thousands of years of
evolution
but their origins are still somewhat
unclear the issue created and bred
an obedient simple-minded race of
creatures to use as an
enslaved workforce humans early humans
couldn't really comprehend the isu
and their intelligence so they viewed
the isu as gods
humans were built to survive but they
weren't intended to be very smart
in fact the isu also created
neanderthals to use as a military force
however to keep humanity under control
the isu crafted technologies known as
pieces of eden
these are a collection of powerful
devices that tap into human brains
through a network of neurotransmitters
to ensure their total obedience these
pieces of eden include king arthur's
sword excalibur
the crystal skulls and the broken spear
of leonidas some pieces of eden are used
for mind control but others can
empower the person using it the swords
of eden grant leadership and charisma
and the shrouds of eden grant powers of
healing and restoration
pieces of eden have been utilized to
help some of the most influential
leaders in history
including genghis khan napoleon and
gandhi
these are the items the assassins and
templars have been fighting over
for centuries the templar order hopes to
exploit the pieces of eden to help them
achieve
a new world order while their enemies
the assassins
seek to guard them but there are certain
humans born without the
neurotransmitters that give pieces of
eden their power
making them immune to the artifact's
mind control abilities
these are human isu hybrids hybrids and
their subsequent bloodlines have an
extra sensory perception
or a sixth sense called eagle vision
also known as odin's sight by viking
assassins
not only did altair ezio bayek and many
other noteworthy assassins have this
hyper awareness
but the sense was also possessed by the
first known hybrids
adam and eve in an ancient isu city
referred to as the garden of eden adam
and eve using their hybrid ability to
resist mind control
stole an apple of eden which doesn't
actually look like an apple at all
this rebellion erupted into a full-scale
war between humans and their so-called
gods the issue
in 75010 bce the first civilization was
more technologically advanced
but humans had the advantage of numbers
big numbers with millions more human
fighters compared to their creators
this civil war went on for a decade with
much higher casualties than the issue
expected
but they were so distracted fighting the
war that they failed to notice an
impending disaster approaching earth
a massive solar flare a small group of
isu referred to as the capital line
triad
who when participating in the war
attempted to prevent the solar flare
the trio made up of minerva juno and
jupiter tried to find possible solutions
and tested them in underground temples
called vols but ultimately
all of them failed after accepting their
fate minerva decided to dedicate herself
to preventing the inevitable
reoccurrence of a solar flare in the
future
while juno focused on her own more
sinister plans
juno didn't exactly want to save earth
she wanted to conquer it
and make humans pay for daring to revolt
against their creators
when minerva and jupiter discovered
juno's motives they quickly
imprisoned her in what is essentially
limbo
as the solar flare approached earth
minerva finally managed to find a
solution to prevent future solar flares
she constructed a pedestal called the
eye that had the power to alter the
patterns and equations of existence
to protect the earth and leave hidden
messages of warning for future humans
but before minerva could use the device
she discovered juno had tampered with it
so that it would set her free from
imprisonment upon activation
refusing to unleash juno maneuver
destroyed the device
sealing the earth's fate to face the
solar flare
when the disaster struck a massive
eruption of magma from the surface of
the sun
flipped the earth's weakened magnetic
field reversing its polarity and
exposing the earth to the sun's
radiation
this event the toba catastrophe scorched
the planet and wiped out the majority of
life on earth
including most of the isu and humans but
not all of them
sometime after the toba catastrophe the
son of adam and eve
kane killed his brother abel to take the
apple of eden previously possessed by
their parents
to pay for his crime kane was branded
with a red cross
which his followers named the mark of
kane hundreds of years later the mark of
cain was adopted as the insignia of the
children of kane's future incarnation
the knights templar after the war and
the toba catastrophe the isu and humans
worked together to rebuild their world
but the isu weren't able to fully
rebuild their population
leading to the inevitable decline toward
their extinction
however they knew another solar flare
would occur eventually
so it took steps to prevent it minerva
built a second eye device and recorded
hologram messages of warning in a vault
underneath what would become
vatican city in rome in these messages
maneuver warned of earth's impending
doom
and spoke of the temples that could save
earth from destruction
built by those who knew to turn away
from war only a hundred years after the
temples were built
the first civilization was almost
completely extinct
and this message was one of the last
remaining vestiges of the first
civilization
after the issue faded into obscurity the
first instance of a modern human
discovering their existence
was by a descendant of adam altair it
wasn't for 300 more years that humanity
would encounter them again
when a descendant of altair the assassin
ezio auditory deference
found minerva's hologram underneath the
vatican ezio told the other assassins
about minerva but they didn't really
understand her true nature and power
even ezio seemed to have a hard time
rationalizing her existence
500 years after ezio his descendant
desmond miles was forced by abstergo
industries
to receive minerva's messages through
the memories of altair and ezio
at the end of assassin's creed iii
desmond bravely sacrificed himself
using the eye pedestal to save the world
but in doing so he unleashed
juno from her imprisonment into the
digital world
to wreak havoc under the guise of saving
humans from themselves
which sounds a lot like thanos but don't
worry juno hasn't been able to achieve
her goal
for now i will save you all
while we don't know too much about
assassin's creed valhalla yet fans are
already speculating the ways the isu and
the pieces of eden could play a role in
the next installment of the popular
series
in valhalla we'll be playing as vikings
but of course every assassin's creed
game involves elements of sorcery
intertwined with earth's
alternative history in the series law
the isu seem to have directly influenced
different polytheistic religions
since many of them have the same names
as roman gods like minerva
juno and jupiter it becomes even more
apparent in assassin's creed origins and
odyssey
when it's revealed that the egyptian and
greek gods are also
actually isu it seems possible that
valhalla could include the isu
as the norse gods like odin thor loki or
freya
in norse mythology valhalla means the
hall of the slain
and is an enormous majestic hall in
asgard ruled by the god odin
the legend says that when warriors died
in combat odin chose the best fighters
and sent valkyries to lead them to
valhalla upon dying so they can aid odin
during the battles of ragnarok
the whole ceiling was thatched with
golden shields and was surrounded by
legendary creatures and the golden tree
glacier
it seems possible that there might be
norse pieces of eden in assassin's creed
valhalla
or even a humanity threatening event
like ragnarok but we'll just have to
keep waiting until november
to find out
for more on assassin's creed valhalla
and other episodes of law escape
including ones on the witcher 3 and the
sims
make sure you keep your eyes peeled to
youtube.com gamespot
this is lucy james reading for miranda
church